les machiavéliques vous êtes
manipulateur et vous êtes montre
[Applaudissements]
jamais je n'ai voté marine
2 dans une tribune une cinquantaine de
sportifs appellent à faire barrage à
l'extrême droite des athlètes de toutes
disciplines appelle donc à voter pour
emmanuel macron il faut défaire de sa
vie c'est quoi les faits on a été
compris et des moins que rien des
métairies en mai vouloir exploiter à moi
je n'ai mas habituel si vous voulez de
2,2 gens qui sont privilégiés qui ne
connaissent aucune des difficultés que
connaissent des millions de français qui
aujourd'hui n'arrive plus à faire le
plein de leurs caddies de leur voiture
bonjour ils
se font plus rêver les plus dominants
pas grave c'est pas d'agitation
bonjour
on voulait résolument
question de nouvelles techniques
des images sont assez dures sont les
policiers de monsieur darmana il faut
s'adresser à monsieur darmanin parce que
moi j'y suis pour rien ce sont mes
service de protection des personnalités
à la même personne le même jour dit vous
êtes journaliste mais monsieur ne l'est
pas parce qu'il dit des choses qui ne me
plaisent pas on a le début d'une dérive
autoritaire cette recette qui consiste à
changer la constitution à sa main sous
prétexte de consulter le peuple qui
consistait à choisir les journalistes
qui consiste à nous dire le même jour
moi
revenir sur la peine de mort je suis pas
contre
qui a créé un scandale au sein des
rédactions parce qu'ils voulaient dans
chaque rédaction choisir les
journalistes qui le suivait bon je crois
que tout ça
démontre une porte de fébrilité de la
part
malgré tous les efforts le vrai visage
de l'extrême droite revient c'est un
visage qui ne respectent pas les
libertés le cadre constitutionnel
l'indépendance de la presse l'écouté
tout à l'heure même si j'ai pas il
devait pas être au courant que j'étais
là donc ils
devaient pas être quand j'étais là parce
qu'il manque de politesse il n'est pas
vulgaire bon jour là d'un coup d'un seul
toute une série d'outrance ont été
proférées
avec une tonalité qui est donnée par le
président de la république d'ailleurs un
qui très brutale qui est très agressif à
mon égard elle peut gagner l'élection
présidentielle et je pense que toute
personne qui dirait que par nature elle
ne peut pas la gagner un sou tromperait
et deux seraient
totalement inconséquente pourquoi il ya
le peut gagner ce qui n'était pas le cas
en 2010 est
en tout cas je vous sais pas si c'est
plus ou moins le cas je pense que c'est
le cas aujourd'hui poignée de main et
des dialogues nous masquer en face à
face avec les français ma nomination
emmanuel macron et marine le pen met de
côté les gestes barrière dans cette
campagne de l'entré deux tours je savais
ferrero les autorités britanniques
auraient informé l'industriel du
chocolat dès le 23 mars d'un risque de
contamination à la salmonelle d'après
les ong football le 23 mars soit douze
jours avant le retrait des rayons des
supermarchés français 12 jours pendant
lesquels les confiseries incriminés sont
restés en vente au large de saint
nazaire il ne reste qu'une pâle à
assembler pour que la première éolienne
en mer française commence à produire de
l'électricité
une pale c'est 30 tonnes de matière à
elle seule l'ensemble de l'éolienne pèse
mille tonnes de quoi résister aux vents
du large des jeunes qui retourne une
voiture de police pour sauver les agents
à bord un geste de civisme salué sur les
réseaux sociaux à marseille le porte
parole du syndicat des commissaires de
police à partager cette vidéo sur
twitter pour remercier l'action d'une
dizaine de jeunes venus à la rescousse
des policiers piégé disparition de
michel bouquet il avait 96 en immense
comédien évidemment de théâtre il a
collaboré avec les plus grands a obtenu
à deux reprises le césar du meilleur
acteur